el epicentro de una crisis migratoria
que muestra pocos signos de
desaceleración el domingo el presidente
Joe biden realizó su primera visita a la
frontera entre Estados Unidos y México
desde que asumió su mandato hace dos
años el viaje de biden comenzó en El
Paso Texas donde se reunió con los
guardias fronterizos en uno de los
puntos de entrada más transitados por
los migrantes en Estados Unidos el
número de migrantes que cruzan la
frontera se ha disparado Durante los dos
primeros años de mandato del presidente
biden con un récord de 2,4 millones de
detenciones registradas en 2022 los
republicanos llevan meses criticando a
biden por sus ataques a la seguridad
fronteriza Así que escuchen el
presidente que provocó el caos en la
frontera Tenía que estar aquí sucede que
llega dos años y 20 mil millones de
dólares tarde y me quedaron paso al
frente y tomar medidas rápidas incluido
el reembolso al estado de Texas por el
dinero que gastamos pero proporcionando
más recursos para que el Gobierno
Federal haga su trabajo
ante la creciente presión política la
semana pasada anunció que su
administración denegaría el asilo a
personas procedentes de Cuba Nicaragua
Venezuela y Haití si cruzaban la
frontera mexicana sin autorización pero
como concesión la Casa Blanca también
presentó una vía de entrada para hasta
30.000 inmigrantes de esos cuatro países
a condición de que cumplan varios
requisitos con este panorama encontrar
un terreno común para el presidente
mexicano Andrés Manuel López Obrador en
materia de migración será un objetivo
clave para el presidente estadounidense
en su asistencia a la Cumbre de América
del Norte en Ciudad de México